[Music]
do you touch my drum set
nope this movie might be the most
non-authentic
and the reason why i say it is that
drumming is all about
beating [ __ ] you're never gonna know if
someone
hits a stick and it's a dent in the
stick unless you don't play
hey gq this is thomas pridgen and this
is the breakdown
[Music]
first up whiplash not quite my tempo
here we go five six
[Music]
downbeat on 18. okay here we go
immediately when i watch whiplash i
laugh because the tempo he gives them is
so
short it's like no one can catch a tempo
if it's that shirt because it's like
you need a little bit of time to like
get your little dance on to get the like
tempo right
and he gives them no time so
[Music]
you're rushing here we go
the conductor is like loki hazing this
guy
and i've been hazed by music directors a
lot of times people tell you that it's
for your own good yeah he's only on you
because he
knows you're good and you can do better
or whatever
but sometimes it's crazy because you
don't really know what people think
you're just thinking that they hate you
and when you're in um school bends
everyone comes from different
dichotomies they come from different
places
and you're all just trying to blend in
and playing the music together that's
all it's about
so i think this is a perfect example of
trying to understand other musicians on
stage i came in on suicidal tendencies
i came in on thundercat came in on mars
volta
and all these things are so different
from each other
but i've had to come in as a person
that's learning the music
trying to channel this sound which makes
a lot of times trying to understand what
people want much more difficult
here we go okay i think he was counting
the music in seven so a lot of times you
play music
usually music is in 4-4 timing so i'd be
like
one two three four one two three four
one two three four
so i think he wanted this song to be in
seven so he was
one two three four five six seven one
two
three four five six seven he was counted
as seven
eight so he wasn't really explaining
that
in the the best form but i don't think
he was explaining anything so the
the drummer is just so nervous he's just
gonna do anything
okay i've never had anybody throw
anything
at me but i feel like people probably
wanted to
let's keep going hold on why do you
suppose i just hurled a chair at your
head neiman
i i don't know sure you do the tempo
were you rushing or were you dragging
when a artist or musician says you're
rushing or dragging
they mostly mean that you are speeding
up the beat or you are
laying behind the beat you can still
play
in a certain bpm and still play behind
or above the beat but he's losing his
mind on this drummer and everyone else
in the room
is quiet and i wish they would help him
because he's getting abused
i don't know
start counting five six seven four damn
it look at me
one two three four one two three four
one
two three no now i'm confused i don't
understand if the is the problem
that he is speeding up the beat or that
he is not
playing in four this is confusing me
because most times musicians when they
play with drummers they always expect
the drummer to keep
the time and they never keep time they
always just rely on the drummer so if
the song is speeding up
and it's starting to race they blame the
drummer and
so with this part tempo and time
signature is not the same thing
time signature has to do with how many
beats a song has
in the phrase it has nothing to do with
how much the speed is
or how fast it is or how slow it is so i
feel like
they're kind of blending in two
different aspects of music
and at this point as a drummer you're
just completely confused because this
guy is just
he's just hazing you at this moment i've
been with some band directors that have
been pretty extreme
sometimes i think musicians are
perfectionists and they don't even know
what they like and so i think that's
kind of probably what's going on in this
clip
because i feel like he doesn't really
know what he wants because we just saw
this music change from 4-4 timing to
7-7-8 timing and now he
doesn't want him to play in seven eight
time and he's done with him
what does that say quarter note equals
215. count me at 215.
a one two three four one two three four
[ __ ] cry
the part where he asks him to count
tempo is really strange to me because
as a drummer i have never been able to
just spot on
or say where 100 bpms are or
160 we know around about where it is but
we don't know for a fact where those
tempos are
so when he starts freaking out about
tempo
that's a little bit off from how i've
done my life
most musicians we like to ask each other
you're like how do you feel it where do
you think the time should be
it's not like muscle memory tempo
reading tempo
is not the same as um reading a chart
he's on this man's ass watching him just
take it
and just keep trying keep trying keep
trying keep trying to do it is another
thing that
a lot of musicians who really want to do
and it makes you thick-skinned i've been
through this
in the gospel world i played with snoop
dogg and felt like i was getting haze
but i've dealt with this and i feel like
in some levels this made me a better
musician
oh my dear god are you one of those
single-tier people do i look like a
double [ __ ] rainbow to you
when he started getting into this guy's
like emotional state
i've had artists try to get me angry in
the studio
and try to force me to play things
multiple times that kind of set me back
because i've been there i feel like this
kid maybe had
a lot of talent and he just was trying
to like push this
wheel out of him or maybe just being
like that
in some level he thought was forcing him
have the will to be like
such a sick musician it didn't seem like
he hated him
he was crazy abusive but it didn't seem
like he hated him
next up wayne's world
so this clip is really funny because
it's kind of like what happens in drum
stores when professional musicians walk
in you see this new item and you just
want to try it out
definitely go in the drum store and then
like now it's more about if the drum set
is like tuned and it sounds you know
really good and they make you want to
you know keep sitting there he sat there
and he was like yo i liked it he's like
this kind of feels good he starts
tapping around
and he notices he's like okay he was
just happy
and i know that feeling because you a
lot of times you like being on a drum
set is
or being on any instrument is somewhat a
relief the waynes world drum set
is bigger than most drum sets most
people play maybe a six piece at most
you know a lot of people play smaller
drum sets
but he's playing like you know four
times up three
floor toms two floor toms two bass drums
that's more
of a early 90s late 80s rocks
you know metal setup now there's a few
drummers who play those setups
tommy aldridge from white snake used to
play a kit
that was yamaha big times big long
times those are called power times
now starting to be defined by genre of
music that you play
i like it when i see that many drums i
feel like i could be more melodic having
that many drums when you go to drum
store you rarely ever see
a drum setup that is fully set up where
you can see
multiple drums so i know i know that
feeling
[Music]
i think when creating a drum solo
the thing that's most important is
connecting with the people who are
listening to you
most times you hear drummers with other
musicians so when you hear a drummer and
he's playing by himself
it's really cool to connect with people
and you have so many different sounds
you can start a drum solo off
real quiet so people have to really pay
attention to what you're
you're playing and then you can build it
up
and you can make people rock i like um
drummers that make drum solos have hills
and valleys because i want you
to lead me off a cliff and make me want
more like
question and answer you'll play one
thing like blah blah blah
blah blah blah crowd crowd crowd crowd
crowd and you know carry on because the
drums is one of the instruments that
plays
the whole time during the show the
drummers who get the most you know
praise are the ones who can captivate
the audience
in a deeper level than they've
captivated than before it's all about
hills and valleys
and making it interesting for the
listener
[Music]
he mixed up the drum solo from toms to
symbols
he was like really into just like
playing this kit
and he detached from being in a place
and i think that's the beauty about
music is that you can kind of like
detach
from reality a little bit i've had
people ask me how long i practice
and i never really think about it
because it's like
like i'm doing it out of love i feel
like he can play
in some level that he has some knowledge
of drums
because like there's just just a way
just the whole um
intellect and authenticity of the whole
video in the movie i think
those guys have some understanding of
instruments
some of the craziest drums those i've
seen is like
mickey d from motorhead takes a really
great solo
travis barker takes a crazy good solo
tommy lee used to have this like cage
that in the air
it will raise in the air and will flip
upside down so the drummers are playing
upside down
and that was pretty amazing to see that
but i've seen some drum solos from guys
people don't know that's just all about
like chops and not about drum gimmicks
chops is a drum
term for intellect or like skill you
have on the drums
that guy got chops so meaning he's been
practicing
and he's been building his skill
drummers definitely have
set solos that they play every night
but you might have one idea that you
start off with
a couple different drum grooves that you
play as like
beats that people can vibe with but
most times most drummers are improvising
ideas that they have
on a drum solo because they want to
impress the crowd
drummers are in the back so when the
drummer gets his time you want to
lengthen it you want to make sure it has
some diversity and something that is
memorable
[Music]
wow next up this is spinal tap he
exploded on stage
[Music]
just like that it just went up he just
was like a flash of green light you know
several you know
dozens of people spontaneously combust
each year
it's just not really widely reported
this spinal tap video is hilarious
because this spinal tap video reminds me
of just all the bands
that have had eight drummers and i've
been part of that i've
played in bands have had four drummers
every time you see them do an
interview they have like some story
about some drummer because people ask
it's decadent of just like the times
because people try to keep these bands
together for so long even having
multiple different musicians if you look
at like black sabbath you know having
multiple singers you're looking at bands
that
the drummer was the most famous person
in the band and now they have a
different drummer
good drama great look good drummer yeah
good job what happened
he died in a bizarre gardening accident
some years back
the drummer is usually just the most lit
person you know the person going out
partying the most you've had drummers
like keith moon driving
rolls royces in the pool steve moon was
blowing up everything drummers like john
bonham
just getting wild they're mocking keith
moon
and they're mocking them john bottom and
just the earlier drummers and so a lot
of drummers have
you know took on this persona is getting
you know
real crazy and i think that drummers
have a mysterious thing to them because
they're not speaking most times you have
to have some kind of quirkiness to be a
drummer it's kind of funny hearing
stories with drummers and things they do
because
i think drummers are the most
interesting part of the
the band usually that is what's
authentic is people who are acting like
rock and roll
and most people at that moment didn't
want to be in the interview so you know
the drummer is the most rock and roll
because he's not at an interview
next up bohemian rhapsody
now i want you to clap on the third beat
this is completely authentic of an idea
and a situation that could definitely
happen as musicians
because i know the power of people
working together this is not far-fetched
i think they came up with this idea and
this music and this beat at a time where
no one else had it this is all about
creativity and timing
some songs like start off with guitar
some songs start off with the drum
pattern
sometimes it could be a melody a lot of
times with bands that's this is actually
the fight of
royalties and publishing who started the
song they're so
crazy what's going on you know if you're
on time
i'm a performer darling not a swiss
train conductor
the way freddie mercury walked into the
clip he could have been a dick but he
was
open he's like oh let's hear it out i
think um coming with the sound has to do
with you guys spending time together
you have to build a sound you have to
work on
the the bass player and the drummer
locking together when i mean locking i
mean
sounding like a cohesive unit the thing
about drum
drum beats in general is they just move
the crowd
and they make people dance in different
ways
[Applause]
this is really cool because it showcases
how important like even as basic of a
beat is that
it can move mountains he tapped into the
most prehistoric thing that we have
musically was just something that was
super just bare minimum
across genres across the cultural they
know everything about this tune
and it's mainly about because it's you
can anyone could do it
you know you need those being a musician
you want to make sure you don't just
like
cater to yourself because you'll make
music people will never listen to so you
try to understand what your audience
likes and
who is coming to your show your audience
is very important i think this
might be to the most degree of most
songs where you just like
the crowd is going to do this man i
don't think i've ever felt freddie
mercury type of
crowd participation when i have been on
stage where the crowd has participated
that connection where people are singing
and playing the same thing is so
spiritual
because that's the reason why music even
exists because this is a therapeutic
thing
people go to these shows to escape their
real life
you want to be able to be a part of the
whole crowd and
especially if the music is uplifting and
it all can be like
oh god because that feeling
is like that feeling is something you
can transcribe
next up that thing you do
[Music]
as drummers we a lot of times get yelled
at for being
speeding up or being too fast or
counting the song off too fast or too
loud this is kind of wild because the
drummer's just like yo i'm a play i
don't care about what's going on
the drummer is usually in control over
the tempo
most times yeah if you want to play a
song a little bit faster
you can push it you know but i think he
was he was pushing a little bit too much
and the crazy part about it is that he
was the most hyped person on the stage
and the audience like you know
gravitated towards his energy the
audience matches the drummer's energy
more than it matches the guitar or
the singer's energy as a drummer you
controlling the tempo you can
you can make people speed up if you're
speeding up too much you'll have a
guitar player or singer telling you to
slow down and they might do their hands
in the tempo they want
which is annoying and embarrassing as a
drummer
but um this is just a thing that ends up
happening on stage oh
come on that's too fast now a lot of the
musicians and a lot of artists they
play shows with click tracks and backing
tracks
you have a click track that counts you
in and everything a lot of bands when
they start playing with click tracks
everything starts sounding like the
record
when they play live and a lot of people
like that because they can
hear the song the way it's been promoted
on the radio
playing two click checks has started to
be a huge thing so
pretty much 95 percent of them artists
that you know
across genres are playing to click
tracks to make sure the tempo is
straight
what i liked about his drumming is that
he was playing traditional grip
and traditional grip for people who
don't know is when you play
your hand like uh like this like not
match grip is when your hand is straight
but
traditional grip is like this where it's
an older style of playing
and so i appreciate that he was playing
traditional grip
and a lot of the older drummers like
charlie watch from rolling stones he
played traditional grip
traditional grip was um was invented
because of marching drums was
was tied around the neck and so the drum
was so close that you could play this
hand like this but the stick was
elongated right here
and so they play like this i think he
definitely got some drum lessons from
somewhere
for him to be playing and looking that
good his hands look loose
he looks like it's not foreign and to
play traditional grip it takes a little
bit of
time you have to spend a little bit of
time to get the strokes
i can tell that he spent his time
learning how to play drums and i
appreciate that
next up drumline
so the thing i like about drumline is i
like the idea of
southern historically black colleges
and drums and that i really liked is
that
watching the idea of a drum battle a
drum battle
consists of two opposing drummers or
drum crews
playing the coolest chops that they
possibly can
you always want to do something new
[Music]
i never personally played marching band
drums
but i grew up in the drum battle culture
people
shedding and playing drums next to each
other so this is
the world that i come from and it's all
about chops
it's all about speed and technique it's
all about creativity
and i think that's what has inspired
this last generation of drummers to be
honest with you
you know hbcus drum lines i think they
take it to another level
because they not only are proficient in
technique
but they also play music that's on the
radio
so you might hear a drum line playing
ludicrous
people love that because when you get to
see you know football players all
hyphy and you hear the drumline come out
with not only are they playing but they
moving and they dancing i just
appreciate the whole aspect
of a drum line and i wish personally
that i was a part of it but i never got
to be a part of it i just watched from
afar
i think the difference between marching
band drummers
and drum set drummers is coordination
mainly because a full drum set requires
four-way coordination
and usually people who are playing a
snare drum or
bass drum or toms they're only using two
limbs
but i think the idea of groove and
you know energy is the same one thing
that
has to be factored in is the size and
the weight of the instruments
like carrying a bass drum you know it
could weigh 30 40 pounds so these guys
are moving around at hot temperatures
so it's a lot of physicality to you know
planning full
uniform and also playing this crazy you
know
technical stuff i wouldn't want to put
one above
each other because they both are
strenuous and difficult nick cannon in
the clip definitely look like he can
play
and someone showed them how to play what
i liked about
the drum lines in this clip is the
dynamics
it makes the the music more creative and
makes
the listener more engaged because you're
not just doing one thing the whole time
nick was throwing in a bunch of
different combinations of rudiments
a rudiment would be like a traditional
pattern that you play on the drums
to loosen up and to create and build
technique
drumming rudiments is essentially a
scale
for drummers you know how piano players
have a scale
the drummers have a scale and it's
called drum rudiments
so one drum roll rudiment would be like
a double stroke roll which would be
um two beats on the right two on the
left so it'd be like this
that's a double stroke roll and then
another drum rudiment would be like a
paradiddle and that sounds exactly how
you're playing it
paradiddle paradiddle paradiddle
paradiddle
right and so you can mix those up so you
could be like
double double double double double
paradiddle
so when you build these ideas up it
creates control
you create um rhythms and you you can
create
technique in which that you can play
things that are outside the box of just
a beat the main thing about drums is
that you're trying to get
all four limbs to be completely mobile
by themselves so yeah that's the good
thing about rudiments
the marching band snare drums are
different from regular snare drums on a
drum set
the martian snare drums have a super
high tension
so they're like they're super tight
where snare drums that i play
and regular drummers play they're more
like loose and
they have some vibrant kind of like tone
to them
and they have kevlar snare drum heads
like kevlar from the bulletproof vest
[Applause]
i haven't been in a situation where
people were so
mad about playing other people's drums
that it just
launched them into a complete tirade
mainly because a lot of times you want
other people to play drums with you
because it's a good
event or thing to do with other people
but if you are like step brothers
and you're like rubbing your balls on
your own that could probably be a bad
situation
so i think it depends on the
relationship you have with this person
but if you know them and y'all kind of
seen each other before it's kind of like
oh okay you're gonna play my drums well
now i'm gonna play your drums but he
took it in a level of disrespect
i think he wanted to punch nick cannon
before cause nick cannon was probably
grilling him on the snare drum
for me i want to win fair and square so
i'm not going to punch you to win next
up step brothers
in step brothers when you see the
padding on the wall
it's indicative of people living next to
other people
so it's like you the hardest part of
being a drummer is that
you are a drummer and you live next to
other people who are not drummers
so a lot of times you have to soundproof
the walls or you play in the basement
you got to play at certain times so your
neighbors don't lose it
um so like watching step brothers and
just seeing like
you know sound sound reinforcement on
the walls
is indicative of you trying to be a
professional drummer
i think the toronto steppers is all
right i don't think it's a best way or a
right way to twirl sometimes you'll even
be doing twirls that are not real
where it looks like it's tutorial but
it's not a real twirl
the art of twirling sticks is one of the
coolest art forms in drumming
if you can manage to not do it too much
most times people only twirl on drum
solos that's like part of drum soloing
is you
need to bust some some crowd please and
twirls twirls and throwing this stick in
the air
are close to the same type of energy
hey man do you touch my drum set
no this movie might be the most
non-authentic
and the reason why i say it is that
drumming is all about
beating [ __ ] so it's like
you're never gonna know if someone hits
a stick and it's a dent in the stick
unless you don't play
most drummers are not really that you
know crazy about
other people playing their drums usually
drummers are just like
in the energy of anybody can play it so
this is a little bit unauthentic unless
you just
really despise a person which goes to
the movie you know
the people who measure between the
symbols and the
the snare are sound like engineers sound
engineers always are measuring they
always are trying to figure out if the
right mic
overhead is the same height as a left
hand overhead
from the circumference of the drum
throne these guys are nuts
drummers are way less into that we
mostly just want to play drums when you
start measuring things and looking if
the stick has a chip on it
you start getting out of drum zone and
you start turning some other thing
wristbands are a thing because your your
arms sweat
and if your arms sweat then your hands
sweat
and then now the sweat is on your sticks
and sticks are falling out of your hand
and when you play show after show after
show and you play
long nights you play harder you start
ripping your hand
craziest thing i ever did was super glue
my whole hand so i can get through shows
because my stick was so ripped up now
they have sticks that are not even
made with wood they have sticks that are
made out of aluminum and they have
sleeves
that are supposed to cushion the shock
of the sticks hitting your palm
we're in 2020 and we have never seen the
world like this
where you going i'm going upstairs
because i'm going to put my nuts hat on
your drum set
okay the worst thing someone has ever
done to my drums
is just start straight up throwing them
in the crowd
i was on tour um and the singer just
kept throwing everything in the crowd
at first it was cool but then he
wouldn't like he wouldn't talk to me
after a while i don't i don't remember
what i did to make him stop talking to
me but fans will be trying to run
out with like a 20-inch symbol which is
this big
they try to run out the front door and
security be like you got a symbol
i win a whole tour playing like a mitch
match bass drum
most drummers want to smash their drums
we all want to be like
green day or like trey cool and people
who have smash drums but some of these
drums are really nice and they
sound good so it's like smashing them i
don't know if i want to do that
next up the mambo kings baby
[Music]
let me just say tito puente
legend straight up legend and i
appreciate watching him
and the thing that i like about
afro-cuban music is that
everybody is involved in this aspect of
creation
creating music and so i love watching
afro-cuban
players and the music and the dancing
and the food
and so this clip encompasses all that
sitting in in clubs is really an art
because you have to be able to blend in
with other musicians who have been
playing the whole night
they've been playing the whole night and
you come up cold after a drink
and you walk up there and you try to do
your thing so tito is a legend and he
lets him come
he's my up so when someone brings you up
there and you have some kind of
gift and you know what you're doing
y'all could have a conversation
and so we talked about drum battling
earlier
but this is not a drum battle they're
having this conversation and
they're you know he'll play one melody
tito play one melody and that
is what i like about drummond even more
so
than any other aspect of it is that i
just like that we all can sit around
and we all can have this conversation no
matter how good you are
you can be playing on your legs no you
could be playing a tambourine my
grandmother would take me to clubs
and um people be playing and they'd be
like tommy come on stage tell me come on
stage
and i'll come on stage and play with all
these other musicians
and that's kind of how i got my whole
big break
and so to just watch a movie encompass
this idea
is so important because that's how
musicians grow and that's how
other musicians inspire other people to
meet musicians they're like i want to do
that i want to get on stage and be able
to get up there with tito puente
and that is what is so cool about music
is that
people can just work with each other and
experience things with each other
i have such a deep love for afro-cuban
drumming and timbaland
a tembali is a drum that's mostly used
in afro-cuban
in salsa music settings it's a
high-pitched drum made out of brass
sometimes steel related to a snare drum
with
thin sticks that are played and thin
heads
you don't see that drum in america that
much it's an
island drum from puerto rico or cuba
or in that area but the timbales also
have bells
so they're playing bales and they're
playing these two drums
one is tuned down and one is tuned up so
and it's really high and they hit the
rim i play timbales a little bit with
the
you plant it more lighter and more
finesse tenbali's have a lot of um
consistencies with playing jazz music
rock is about
brute force kind of speed like jazz
and salsa it's about finesse and
how to be like sharp and like it's sexy
it's like a
it's different thing tembali is a really
delicate and
light i never met him but he's a god and
he'll just be in a movie shoot with
tidal pauliente just playing with you it
was supposed to be amazing
because he's so sick next up vice versa
[Music]
i played in the mall and i just know
that energy of playing in the mall and
it'd be
so loud it was the mall the mall is not
set up for acoustic music i have
experiences where you are you go out and
you start playing music
and you don't know who around you also
plays music
and i think it's pretty cool
[Music]
i've been at malls or shopping areas and
you just be like wow
by people and i feel like this clip is a
lot about that you never know what
you're going to see
you go outside and maybe this kid is
playing keyboard in 2020 that's what i
actually missed the most
i miss going out and not knowing what
you'll see
at a mall like i miss them all i mean we
can't go to the ball we can't hang out
this clip is isn't decadent of just
people normal people having a little bit
of music talent
just a tiny bit of musical talent and
coming together
and having a jam session like my friends
we have these jam
sessions that'll you know start at nine
o'clock and we'll end it two
and the club will close and then we'll
go to another spot
and we'll play from three to seven and
we'll wake up whenever we do and do it
again
that's the joyous thing about being a
musician
and jamming is about technique and vibes
you can change a gem
by just the energy you come off with and
think about jams that are so dope is
that you don't never know who's gonna
play
so you might have some guy who's a real
novice musician playing with a
a virtuoso or you might have a guy who
is um you know only plays one style of
music and he plays maybe classical piano
and now he's playing in a hip-hop
setting it just also goes with just how
diverse music is in it as a whole
jamming most times is good because you
get to sharpen your chops
you get to work with other people you
get to meet people you get to
you know most times jams happen at times
you're not expecting to play
this clip makes me hopeful for like just
the future the idea of like the first
real concert we all can like dance next
to each other and it's not
like this it was something to people
moshing and
and stage diving and and pushing
each other and sweating on each other
and just like
be human you know thank you guys for
watching all these clips with me
thank you for tuning in to the breakdown
peace